what if it was like osama bin laden's
chick-fil-a bin laden's best your boy's
still going dude okay and then there's a
big sign that says
al-qaeda's number one favorite
and then i'll be like look i don't agree
with everything you guys say but i'm
sure you guys have some valid points and
he's like oh cool do you want a number
11
or number nine that's all you could
choose to get i'll do the combo i'll get
a side of pentagon sauce what if they
were like pro asian hate
i'd secretly go
would you i
you wouldn't go if they uh if whenever
you bought chick-fil-a
you had to share an emotional thing
about yourself
he's like dirty guys i share emotional
things with you guys all the time yeah
name one name one thing you guys just
don't think i'm telling the truth name
one thing about your [ __ ] cold
watermelon
um today we're talking about guilty
pleasures okay my newest thing go to
trader joe's this is like what i do i'll
buy a watermelon and i'll be like
literally falling asleep shut up dude
but like i honestly really but that's
the [ __ ] up part